it's great to welcome to the program
today Alex Kokan offski who's the CEO
and co-founder of dream team which is
doing a lot of interesting stuff within
the eSports world and beyond alex great
to talk to you today hi how it's going
so I mean listen there's people in our
audience who know a lot about eSports
and there's people who don't and from an
economic perspective I've been reading
more and more about eSports and this is
this is a bigger and bigger world how
can we quantify the size of the eSports
economy at this point in time how big is
it yeah I think these sports started
developing rapidly from the past another
five six years yeah it was kinda a
golden age at the moment there was
almost 500 million
involved people in mobile news sports
and the industry will reach more than a
billion in this year and what are the
primary sort of financial drivers of the
industry I mean I know that there are
eSports teams that are sponsored there's
obviously huge advertising dollars that
exist within eSports there are
tournaments which are heavily sponsored
and funded but like give us a sense of
some of the where the money is in the
industry so I think the core drivers are
on the one hand there are sponsors of
course as I said the end there is a
professional ecosystem with steam story
means professional players live
broadcasting studios and the main
revenue for those kind of parties driven
by sponsors and media right sales yeah
eventually as the real Sports is sports
pretty much the same on the other hands
and I think that's the key factor right
now also that's game developers they're
making a sport eSports a core marketing
tool and that cheapening dozens of
millions of dollars into prize money and
promotion of the sports market so if you
want to create or join an eSports team
how do you do it I mean is there any
kind of sort of centralized
infrastructure to do that or is it
happening
ad-hoc yeah that's a really good
question because first of all it's pain
in ass yeah and if you completely but no
if you have zero knowledge about the
eSports or like as an insider on the
highest level you have no idea how
complicated and how hard it is meanwhile
as I was as I've been a team owner for
past ten years I would sell it right now
we're kind of was a dream team enemies
ever since we are doing we're trying
redeveloping the solution that will help
you that streamline this team management
team creation process and just you can
do it with the two clicks of your mouse
yes so talk a little bit about dream
team and what what it is that you're
building here in order to step in and
try to solve these problems I mean how
can you so you talk about two clicks but
how do you streamline this process yeah
so dream team is kind of the first
infrastructure platform for eSports and
competitive gaming in general and we are
solving the problem of those gamers yeah
founded to me lots of gamers who wants
to build their teams improve their
skills in find players yeah as well and
earn money yeah so on one hand we are
kind of helping the gamers to advance
from novice to amateur in a desire to
professional so we making this like an
ax we are helping to me we're helping
them to make this leap from novice to
amateur and by providing an ultimate
tools for recruitment management and
analytics and so on the one hand on the
other one using blockchain smart cortex
we are building kind of one of a kind
payment gateway whenever uniting players
teams tournaments and sponsors and
ensuring all financial and operation
between those parties and talked a
little bit about I mean when you say the
financial elements between the parties
somebody who's not familiar with this
might say what what is he what is he
talking about like what are the
financial things that need to be managed
can you talk a little bit about that
yeah so eSports market booming rapidly
growing one of the fastest growing
digital industry on the planet meanwhile
it's still
like there were there are still some
problems first it's like fraud or
non-delivery yeah the teams tournament
sometime tournaments not paying prize
money teams not receiving the
sponsorship money that they should
sometimes team owners tricking their
players not paying the salaries and so
on market is still very fragmented so
there is no entry point at this type of
pace and there is no pass yes like how
you can advance how you can kind of
streamline your revenue or how you can
earn money so by financial side of
things we say that's on this kind of on
our platform what we are ensuring all
financial operations so if you want to
pay out a salary from a team to a player
coach manager like whoever if you want
to receive a prize money sell your
sponsorship media rights transfer the
players so your advertisement or even
merchandise or digital memorabilia you
can do everything inside of a dream team
do you have to be like a super serious
player to be using this platform and you
talk about amateur to professional but
you also talk about novice to amateur
I'm guessing most people are not
destined to become professional gamers
so the core and the core sinking is like
we need we where we are lowering the
barrier yeah of entry from millions of
dollars and dozens of years which I
personally spent to I don't know
just like few bucks a month and five
minutes to set up we would love to bring
this mass adoption to each person
competing competitive gaming so any kind
of player sitting anyway so in the
suburbs of Boston LA Kiev Berlin
wherever he's sitting he can just build
grow manage and monetize his teams like
professional clubs do is every game by
default compatible with the platform or
do the games need to be introduced to
the platform one at a time yeah so at
the moment there are different games
with different kind of API there are
like games a good like with
API or is a poor API so we are building
something on top of this API to fetch
the data to get the player profiles and
reach team profiles and whatnot so to
some extent we're introducing one game
after another but we have course
starting with the most popular and with
the most competitive titles on the other
hand in the end of the day we are
platform agnostic we're game agnostic so
we would love to it like you know ten
thousand games and people can like the
develop their very skills there are
teams clans and their personality as
well as our money in any game that's it
that they want so underlying this there
is a blockchain and there is a
cryptocurrency
let's talk about each of them sort of
one at a time question one why do you
need a blockchain why does this benefit
from a blockchain so using the
blockchain in majority we're using those
to ensure all financials like a
transaction between the parties and the
core we here it's like we don't want to
be like serve body or like an agent we
would love to two parties connect
directly peer-to-peer and be able to
like May they're older like I'm
financial or like any kind of payments
directly yeah and that's why we are in
majority the blockchain powered is
brutalizing is based on the smart
contracts and solution which we are
building for the platform and then as
far as the dream-team cryptocurrency
what does it do
how is it useful and what are the sort
of economics of it yeah so dream tube
token let's interpret from currency this
we're using on a one hand for you can
use it for one-time purchase and already
in q4 2019 we will introduce everything
that you might even imagine yes like
it's like a shop with a lot of stuff
inside which you can buy only by using
like a dream team talking the users will
be introduced and they will have
opportunity to purchase this talking
directly from the exchange yeah so it
will be like an app we will build some
sort of the solution whenever they don't
need to go on exchange but we will build
it right on our platform that's a one
part and into in 2020 we will start
introducing smart contacts one by one so
the first one which we see that as the
most value
that's smart conduct whenever do you can
pay out the Sailor to a player-coach
manager I don't know any kind of person
yeah and as well as transfer market so
teams can be sound buy players when it
comes to the sort of roadmap or the
timeline of the rollout of all of these
different things where are you now where
are you looking to be by the end of 2019
what's going to be more of a 2020 part
of it so right now we are due to in
November 2017 so in a one health one and
a half year we are reaching almost 1.5
million users we have three games on the
platform it's counter-strike League of
Legends and the recently introduced
epics legends approximately we have
about 1.1 million players 1.2 million
players and 300,000 teams already and by
the end of 2018 as being said we would
love to launch this kind of a first
activity on the platform so you can
utilize all these tokens and all and
whatnot
the other we're going to add one more
game for tonight and introduce team
management models so you can manage your
clan or a team really easily and 2020 I
think it's it's extensive growth and
expansion so we are planning to add four
more new titles at least maybe up to six
we're adding to build analytics tools
and we're any and we going to introduce
smart contracts that people can utilize
on the platform can you talk a little
bit about so you know in the last year
and a half or so there's been what some
people describe as a crypto winter where
a lot of the bigger crypto currencies
lost significant value and then over the
last month there's been a significant
uptick and recovery in a lot of the same
major crypto currencies does what you're
doing depend at all on what is going on
in the broader crypto markets or does it
exist in a completely siloed and
separate space yeah that's really good
question and I think to a certain extent
all top currencies here all projects
right now a dependent a hammer dependent
on the market condition
yeah unfortunate that the nature of the
cryptogram
meanwhile I think the more features and
the more utility will introduce on a
dream team the more standalone kind of
position we can take yeah and the last
little bit dependent on the market
conditions or oh so we're singing in two
three years the only it will be like
completely separate from what's going on
in the market because that's eventually
completely different with different
project with different ability and
there's different functions available so
people if people go to see what you you
know you talk about 2017 and people can
read about your ICO last year which
correct me if I'm wrong raised is it ten
million dollars yeah that's correct so
when somebody reads that you raise ten
million dollars and then they hear about
what you're doing I think there would be
questions about what is the money get
used for is it required for
infrastructure like is it hardware is it
being paid in salaries for developers
what is it exactly how does that money
translate into what you're building yeah
I think that's first of all as an app
and never tech business yeah it's all
about irony yeah so we're a team of
hundred people sitting keep Ukraine and
spoiled him sitting in LA or like CTO
chief marketing officer chief product
officer and I'm we relocated to LA I've
relocated to LA and those guys have been
there for a while I'm first of all of
course that stuff and I ready
yeah that's maybe 50% of the costs then
of course its marketing we have a
marketing budget spending right now we
do have an extensive growth and to have
really solid numbers you need to flush
not act like a flush you need to spend
money on the market and that's what
we've been doing Rubin in partnership
with top tier events like ESL star our
partner with up to your team's like
phonetic Navi we run couple of campaigns
influencer marketing with more than like
annum 200 different influencers on
YouTube and twitch so it was really
costing and still we are we raising
money as like in the venture capital so
we raised five million round around from
angriff capital those guys early
investors in Skype weeks let go it was
our sit around and
or the next year we will proceed to the
serious a it's a bigger chang you can
learn much more about dream team at
dream team dot GG i've been speaking
with alex Cokin offski who's the CEO and
the co-founder of dream team
alex super interesting stuff thanks for
talking to me thank you